questo ragazzo è benvenuta quest'ultimo
episodio di paranormal hk su proprio
mancare mezz'oretta ma se come vediamo
che cosa ci cavo fuori speriamo iddio
non delusa perché se no potrei
commettere un omicidio però già ce ne
sono stati tanti durante il gioco
cosa è successo è uscito siamo ritornati
nel corridoio ovviamente allo qua c'era
la zia adesso spunta la zia del tar
davvero non c'è un punto noi posso
nascondermi aiuto vero cagato addosso
l'altra volta
meno male visto rigato jumps caro la
madonna che brutta e quindi si no vabbè
ascoltavi non posso mica continuare così
spunta dai muri e spunta a caso quark
cavalca un disputa di nuovo no ragazzi
non la vedo dove sei tu
dietro c'è la porta ti prego
e vabbè
che ansia santo iddio basta famiglia
aggiunge alla porta madonna apri apri
apri a prima ma che me ne frega del
telefono che è un porca vacca 6 partita
bomba stessi sogno pronto prendi il
rilevatore di fantasmi ricordati si
abbia paura di che ti va bene
i rilevatori fantasmi quello che ci
stava in coso peace inside che gli
elevatori i fantasmi che la bussola
getting the parking lot al cielo la
telecamera bellissimo si appella a tutti
i ragazzi di questo nuovo blog di
fantasmi vamonos sì però state calmi è
dio c'è l'uscita uscita uscita uscita
uscita uscita è chiusa figure un
ascensore detto proprio lui lo trova lo
castiga ragazzi l'ascensore ascensori
negli horror non sono mai indicati e
troppo bene però che fanno l'unico
ascensore che per uscire di premere un
tasto e questo siamo nel parcheggio
attraverso il parcheggio è entrerà
macchina di chi chi non si sa c'è
l'ascensore si apre con un tasso e sta
portano va bene sono in un parcheggio o
aiuto porca vacca e non mi e non corre
non corre non corre zoppo e zoppo non
corre non lo sto correndo ragazzi
corri maccari madonna impedito dopo
andare lì impedito era un corre e che
devo fà mi chiamo alberi madonna guarda
perché calcio di provincia e macori che
cammini chen satana guarda anche corsa è
ma cos'è che devi essere io sia in volta
però per l'amor di dio almeno cori norma
ha mica mai visto che sono entrarvi che
ha mai visto
mica mai vi dove sarò andato marc
marquez gioco è è visto
beh meno male che rilevatori fantasmi fa
vedere esattamente dove la zia la vedo
che si muove non capisco bene dove sta
andando però ok ok e lì ho capito come
io come la sud come la superò con lui
l'ho amato ongina solleva le macchine
cioè non ti puoi neanche parlare con la
macchina
il cristo santo è di aguero skatea ho
capito ma come ci arriva dall'altra
parte io far di giri allucinato walker
haga ci dovrei essere teoricamente poi
non lo so
uscii cosi li ho tirati penoso quando
schiaccia qualcosa se è quindi non so
cosa sia successo a posto uscita a
destra uscita al sempre a destra uscita
a sinistra
urca [ __ ] porca cosa devo fare
non lo so
cagato nelle mutande cosa doc che c'era
che non so più dove devo andare vi giuro
cambio uscita all'ultimo perché non si
capisce ce l'ho fatta dai aiuto ok sto
cambiando uscita sempre perché madonna
perfetto un casino cielo la macchina la
macchina entro l'avanti
tanto il mio eccoci
accelera accelera ti investo brutto
pezzente l'ho presa a tutto sto casino
investito il fantasma sto guidando la
macchina lega la prima volta la mia vita
non è vero però che almeno la prima
volta quella quando la patente non è
vero neanche questo ti investo ma stava
davanti ma come cosa devo fare
devo investire la zia è piuttosto casinò
dove investire a si è però non ho ben
capito il senso è certo anche perché lei
si teletrasporta quindi un certo punto
l'aveva ceduto non la vedo quindi o la
colpiscono nel mentre che devono seguire
la bussola lo seguì la vita no no non si
non capisco maledizione
staremo qua mamma ma ho preso una
colonna triathlon sbloccato ma che è un
casino il dietro la ho investito un
fantasma no alla fine mi ha spaccato la
macchina è però allegro senti polverino
manicure è un altro giorno tutto sto
casino per un ma toccato io ho investito
il fantasma guarda tutti camminano in
chilling in c ling noi è come se non
stesse facendo niente
sei proprio boom bravo sta in cina in
fratello mio affacci luke razzista roba
o salve potevo arrivarci anche
dall'esterno a noi invece no
michela musica ripartita
ok tutto a posto tutto a posto tutto a
posto tranquilli non sto capendo niente
di quello che sta succedendo mi siedo
che cazzo mi riprende ma che cos'è il
grande fratello cos'è sta roba
videocamere sto capendo
io non ho capito niente
locke l'ocse finalmente vivo e sveglio
si finalmente libero dal di dal dalla
malattia e dalla paura dal dolore space
dove siamo dove è che ti lascia che io
la salvi e usciamo da qui insieme non
uscire da qui perchè perchè dovrei farlo
questo posto è perfetto per me
finalmente questo posto è rimasto
stabile interconnesso finalmente il mio
capolavoro è completo non posso non
riesco più aspettare per godere del mio
lavoro
riposati a lungo quanto preferisci
[Musica]
fiorello ti prego dammi una mano a
capire quello che è successo tutto mi ha
detto corri vai vai e sta succede
qualcosa
non ho capito il finale veloce e tutto
cambia in tutto il resto del gioco ma il
finale non l'ho capito
c'è più o meno una nota va bene che
cristo no no no questo non lo potete
dire quindi c'è un sequel e lo faranno
allora vi dico la verità vi dico la
verità per me sono molto sincero questo
è stato uno dei più bei giochi horror
degli ultimi tempi perché è fatto
proprio bene a livello di jobs che la
livello di dinamica
quindi niente da dire veramente un gran
gioco un gioco della madonna non s'è
capito un gatto finale ma come un
problema mio non una vostra molto figo
questo ragazzi era paranormal hk
veramente semplice ragazzi con la serie
anche come al solito se vi è piaciuto
iscriviti al canale schiacciate la
campanella abusivamente aggiornati sono
i video che escono e inizieremo una
serie horror magari e noi come sempre
ragazzi fatemi sapere anche no scusate
questo
fateci sapere cosa ne pensate del finale
e datemi qualche spiegazione in più
perché mi piace leggere i commenti
soprattutto quando finisco una serie e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video è la ragazza
[Musica]